16 of the funniest comedy podcasts in
the entire world when Head to Head last
month until only one Champion remained
voted on by you guys the best community
of Comedy fans on the internet in
today's video we're going through the
results of each round and finally
crowning the 2023 podcast March Madness
Champion round one started up hot with
The Joe Rogan Experience versus hey babe
for this tournament each podcast was
represented by a recent clip from their
show and comedy fans got to vote on
which clip they wanted to advance The
Joe Rogan Experience clip featuring
guests Matt and Shane made quick work of
Chris and Sao winning this matchup 1096
to 528 next up was the Yvonne in this
past weekend up against number one live
podcast in the world killed Tony this
bracket was made using a random online
generator so there was no official
seating but man I would have put both
these guys maybe as one seeds if you ask
me this past weekend came out with a 957
to 722 Point win to move on and face Joe
Rogan in round two moving on to the
bottom left section where we had the Tim
Dillon show defeating are you garbage by
a margin of just 76 votes we also had an
electric first round upset in this
region with Chrissy chaos holding on to
at 826 to 711 vote Victory sending home
the PowerHouse two bears one cave over
on the top right of the bracket we had
flagrant mopping the floor with tiger
belly in the first round moving past
them with ease next up we had the Andrew
Santino Bowl bad friends vs whiskey
Ginger no big surprises here as bad
friends dominated their first round
matchup raking in almost 1200 votes
which was by far the most votes for any
clip in the entire first round I want to
say this go ahead it is your sober
birthday so happy birthday
well finally something
oh my gosh something you know you're
that's that's something okay can I tell
you something do you know you didn't
even wish me happy birthday on my
[__] real birthday this year it's not
the same why
I was born into the [__] world yeah
we all were
and I wish you Happy Birthday on your
[__] birthday yeah and I think I mean
it was thank you but
I mean what yeah next up we have the
Mark Norman custody battle taking place
we might be drunk for Tuesdays with
stories this Mark vs Mark matchup being
drawn was definitely the worst part
about having the seating being random
but regardless we might be drunk was
able to cruise to an easy 970 to 523
vote Victory finishing up the first
round here we had two of my personal
favorite shows squaring up round one
which you really hate to see I know a
lot of you probably agree your mom's
house versus Matt and Shane's secret
podcast going head to head with the dogs
ultimately pulling away in the end to
advance the round two the elite eight
started off with a heavy hitting of a
matchup as humanly possible The Joe
Rogan Experience versus this past
weekend two of the biggest comedy pods
in the world but the results were not as
close as you might think theovan made
quick work of JRE advancing to the final
four with a cozy 861 to 595 vote win the
next matchup was between the Tim Dylan
show and Chrissy chaos this one was a
little bit closer but still the Underdog
Story continues and Kirsty Cinderella
moved on to face this past this weekend
in the next round over on the other side
of the bracket we started off with some
chalk with bad friends beating flagrant
but things got a little bit more
interesting in the Matt and chain secret
podcast versus we might be drunk matchup
down below the drunk Army rallied hard
this second round putting up 1400 votes
to knock out the shaman and young bull
and punch we might be drunk's ticket to
the final four this year's comedy
podcast March Madness Tournament final
four came down to this past weekend
versus Chrissy chaos and bad friends
versus we might be drunk comedy fans
really showed up to vote on these final
matchups especially with the first one
this past weekend versus Chrissy chaos
what about uh Kanye West you think he's
coming back to what I just like Kanye
West I listen to his music Still I don't
care I like Kanye West I never I never
really listened to him there's no you
know no I mean that thing where we
faster longer
hanger I like that thing and otherwise I
could not whistle you a single has a
rapper ever tried to collaborate with
you somehow
that sounds like like a a rapper tried
it yeah he tried yeah a rapper tried to
collaborate with me but I I maced him
yes no uh did you ever get to meet
Michael Jackson ah damn it man I wish I
did though you know that was what
[__] 10 when he died damn that would
have been the time to meet him yeah yeah
there was a whopping 5 000 votes for the
Rat King in this past weekend which up
to this point in the tournament was more
than quadruple any other vote total so
far but in true chaotic fashion the
Chris's Stefano supporters came out to
vote in droves and put up over 10 000
votes to send Chrissy D to the finals
where he faced off with his good friends
Mark Norman Sam Morel who defeated the
bad friend's crew by a score of 589 to
281 so we got Kirsty chaos first we
might be drunk in this year's final
match up I'm not gonna lie there was
more than a few people claiming this was
rigged somehow because of how unexpected
this Championship matchup was but that's
Madness baby anything can happen plus
it's worth noting that we might be drunk
and Chrissy chaos were the two podcasts
who promoted this tournament directly to
their fans so really it was no surprise
to see them meeting in the finals
championship voting stayed open for
three days and this was the only round
of the whole tournament that we hid the
vote count from the public to build some
anticipation after a hard-fought month
we only had two teams remaining and with
the eternal glory of being crowned the
winner of such a prestigious tournament
weighing in the balance things were
tense everyone was on the edge of their
seats waiting to see who won this thing
I'm pretty sure this tournament would
have been national news if it would have
went on for just one day long longer
this was such a big deal I'm just
kidding I'm trying to build some more
anticipation before announcing the
winner maybe let's watch both these
clips and then we'll do the big reveal I
was just listening to something that
they were saying that Russia and China
this guy predicted that Russia and China
uh will cease to exist in about 30 to 40
years because of their birth rate they
were saying that basically the China One
kid China rule that they had implied you
know uh years ago so many Chinese no but
they said that they lie about their
numbers that you think that there's more
than there are they said that the
problem is with China is 90 of their
population is like over the age of 40 or
something like that so like you can't
you will cease to exist as a and same
thing with Russia they're not they can't
sustain their birth rate and they're the
most on they're some of the unhealthiest
people in the world they have a life
expectancy at like to like 59.
yeah but again these are look at the
look at who this is
these places where it's just yeah
there's articles all over the place that
say like that one China is ceasing to
exist as you read like is declining as
you're it's a new idea yeah but this guy
was on China gonna be here for a long
time
China's gonna be here oh is China going
to be long time
China gotta love you long time Joe one
time I heard that the algorithm can tell
if you're gay before you know oh boy and
I was like I'm screws is terrifying on
the internet yeah yeah why because just
by what you look at how long you hold
how long you stare at Mateo or whatever
you know if that's the case that
explains the videos
but there's such a thing as an
admiration stare doesn't mean you're gay
of course
yeah
intervention who can't appreciate a dick
in the end
I like it that's all the prostate is I
mean I had that done you guys too young
for that go again yeah get it yeah oh my
good looking doc too who loves to hang
out there for a little while make
yourself comfortable
what's the procedure like
two in there yeah
two I think it was two two doctors
one was filming what are you gonna do
so wait got the milking I got it did you
did it feel great because they always
say it's the best thing ever I mean I
must be free to get milked you just got
tested oh I didn't get milk that's what
I'm asking no yeah just go and see if
it's swollen or anything it's like a rub
and Tuck I don't think that's what
doctors do
his name could be Doc I think I was at
the barber why not
I get my prostate check because I'm 40 I
was 46. yep I just turned 47 last week
it does die early
with no further Ado it is my pleasure
and honor to announce this year's 2023
joke World comedy podcast March Madness
Tournament champion presented by watch
Comedy live congratulations we might be
drunk hell of a program they got going
on over there I would not be surprised
to see we might be drunk dominate this
tournament for years to come this could
be the start of the next great Dynasty
and podcast clip tournament history I'm
gonna get a trophy in the mail soon
going over to we might be drunk thank
you to everyone who voted this year you
guys made this a really really cool
thing for the entire comedy community to
get to enjoy just based off your
participation alone same to Chrissy
chaos and we might be drunk huge shout
outs to both of these pods for sharing
the voting link on their social medias
it definitely just made it more fun for
everyone involved this year to feel like
these comedians cared about winning this
silly stupid little tournament or at
least knew that it was going on and
sharing it in their sections to their
fans directly super cool feeling thank
you again for everyone who voted
everyone who shared the links and we'll
see you again next year for the 2024
joke World comedy podcast March Madness
Tournament
[Music]
thank you